good evening and welcome everybody
i know we're social distancing but
please don't be shy i think we can have
a few more people perhaps a meter apart
at least
move closer to the front if you can
excellent okay welcome everybody
thank you so much for joining us here
tonight at the national design
center and a big thank you and a welcome
of course to everybody that's watching
us
online via the the live stream telecast
my name is susie annetta and i'm
editor-in-chief of design anthology
magazine and i'm going to be your mc
this evening
it's a great honor for design anthology
to be partnering with the design
singapore council on this landmark
exhibition and it's indeed a pleasure
not to mention a logistical miracle for
me to be here tonight
for the opening ceremony of visions of
the future
this year has been a challenging year
for all of us
and perhaps one of the few comforts to
be found is
in the understanding that we're all in
this together
and while there may be many similarities
in our experiences this year
our responses and our output vary
greatly
as seen by the work that's on display
here this evening
while we speculate on what the new
normal may be
or what life might look like post
covered
what is clear is that savvy designers
brands
and in fact governments are using this
situation
as not a serious setback or an obstacle
but an opportunity to see what can be
achieved through adversity
and whether through ingenuity we can in
fact design
ourselves a better future
now before i make introductions for
those of you who might
be wanting to take photos of the
exhibition and the works on display
please share them on social media and if
you do that please tag design singapore
council
at design singapore and design anthology
which is at
design anthology dot asia and feel free
to use the hashtags better by design
and visions of the future there is a
filter
called visions of the future that you
can use and some specially created
stickers
that you can find under singapore design
now without further ado i would like to
invite
mark we executive director of design
singapore for his opening remarks
mark
thanks susie ivan um
wow we've only been back to the national
design center a few times this year
and this is definitely the first
exhibition
um since we closed and we had circuit
breaker
so it's actually really memorable and i
think
it's interesting to see what event with
50 people feels like
is this better okay
[Music]
so good evening everyone um welcome to
the visions of the future exhibition
a showcase by eight emerging singapore
design talents and entrepreneurs
this exhibition was actually meant to
take place at milan design week
this year but due to the pandemic the
exhibition had to
adapt instead of focusing on the
negativity surrounding the situation
this change in plans open a world of
opportunities
and we actually use design to address
new challenges brought upon
by the pandemic the seven pieces
that will be unveiled at the exhibition
today showcase the strength of singapore
design talent
who are able to respond to global
problems
the exhibition is curated by local
design consultancy and president design
award
winner recipient forest and wale
and they handpicked these designs for
their visionary approach
to current issues and how they address
the pandemic reality
we actually currently live in from
empowering the elderly to bringing joy
to the simple
but important
[Music]
to bringing joy to the simple but
important act of hand washing
the exhibition highlights the
significance of design
in safeguarding our health and
well-being
there will also be an online component
to the exhibition
and we hope to see you at the panel
discussions and do tune in to the
podcast
where you'll get to interact and hear
from the designers themselves
through the work presented at the
visions of the future exhibition
you can actually see the passion
creativity and resilience
that these emerging design talents
actually have
we encourage you to actually collaborate
with these emerging talents
so that together as a society we can
thrive in challenging times and
really create a better future through
design
the design singapore council is actually
proud to be able to support and develop
the capabilities of these promising
young talents and we look forward to
seeing these designers continue to grow
in their practice
and impact our society economy and
quality of life
we will continue to run similar
capability development initiatives
they aim to help singapore designers
produce high quality work
so they can great gain greater mind
share and really kind of expand
their reach beyond our shows and we
encourage local emerging design talent
to also participate in any of our future
initiatives
i would like to thank our partners
design anthology
she flew in did stay so she actually got
on the plane right
and wendy and gustavo from forest and
whale for working
together with us and pleased to enjoy
the exhibition
and we hope you'll find inspiration and
visions of a great future
and this i might say it's a really
amazing and beautiful
beautifully done exhibition so enjoy the
night thank you
thank you mark i would like to now
invite
wendy and gustavo the curators of the
exhibition from forest and whale to
make their opening remarks
um so when we were asked to curate an
exhibition of emerging designers
to bring to the milan design week in
late 2019
we made the decision not to come up with
a brief that the designers would respond
to
but instead we wanted to get a
collection of future narratives
seen through the eyes of our young
designers and so we had a public
open call in which we had a lot of
entries that were from
existing projects of our young designers
and naturally many of these were the
thesis projects of
these young graduates and so what you
see here the projects that are finally
curated
um have the depth of research and the
rigor
of a design process that is more than a
year long
and i think on hindsight this was
probably
the best decision that we've made
because a few months down the road the
pandemic struck
milan design was canceled and has been
cancelled again for the next year
and the world was in chaos however the
projects that you see here they are
grounded
in the social inclusion you know study
of user behavior
material exploration rethinking of
production systems
and also thinking about product life
cycles you know all the issues that
our young designers are really motivated
about and also the same
issues that have become more apparent
due to the public health crisis
and so i think the pandemic has only
served
to make the societal relevance of these
projects
even greater right and i just want to
share
the words of neurologists and writer
oliver sex
and he was reflecting on the history of
science and medicine
and he wrote and i quote the greatest
creative achievements
arise not only from extraordinary gifted
men and women
but from there being confronted by
problems of enormous universality and
magnitude and
that sums up the design challenge of our
generation
and the essence of this exhibition so i
hope you enjoy
seeing the exhibition today before you
walk away wendy i would actually like to
invite you to say a few words also about
the design
of the exhibition space if you don't
mind right
so when we were asked to think about the
exhibition design
we basically had to reset and think
about exhibition design for singapore
we were very inspired by the viral
transmission projection curves right
which we see
as waves and now we see the second and
third waves of pandemic breaking
over cities across the world and so we
were inspired by that to create these
pedestals that you see here today
where we use the wave structure to
create division
and social distancing in an exhibition
experience
and every project is exhibited in three
or four stories instead of one
single pedestal so you're invited to
stand in the squares
the parallelograms to read the
the exhibition the purple one stands for
the
beginning of each narrative and
there goes the flow right thank you so
much wendy
that's amazing thank you so again a big
thank you to all of you i know it feels
a little bit strange to be at a real
event this year so
thank you for coming to join us here
tonight and for everyone that's joined
in for the live stream online
please don't forget to visit visions of
the future
dot sg to read more about each of the
designers and their works
and to stay updated about the exciting
program of
online and real life events that we have
planned
through the course of the exhibition
thank you again
have a great night
dear world once upon a time
we had an impossible idea to turn sea
into land and land into one of the
busiest airports in the world
a gateway for dreamers a runway
for believers
but now our world is not quite the same
we are in the toughest crisis of our
generation
our skies are quieter and our streets
too
but it's also in this quiet
that you can hear the belief
and in the emptiness
see the resolve and resilience of our
people
[Music]
and just like once upon a time we now
look not
at what we see but at who we
are and not at what if but what's next
a people who stare in possible
challenges in the face
and say no we won't be beaten
planes can be grounded but our spirit
never dear world together
we will rise again
you